Big Bang Theory star melissa rauch has
some big news the 37 year old actress
and her hubby Winston are expecting
their first child this fall Melissa took
to Instagram to make the exciting
announcement though not in the way you
might think she shared this cropped
photo of herself and directed followers
to her bio for a link to this glamour
article announcing her pregnancy the
road to Parenthood hasn't been easy for
the actress in the articles she admits
that the only statement regarding her
pregnancy that doesn't make her feel
like a complete fraud is that she's
expecting her first child she continues
her statement in the third person quote
she is extremely overjoyed but if she's
being honest due to the fact that she
had a miscarriage the last time she was
pregnant she's pretty much terrified at
the moment that it will happen again
Melissa will no doubt be a fabulous mom
even her CBS cast meets admit she's
great with kids of your castmates
who would you most likely trust you a
babysit each other well I mean Simon's a
dad so I guess I pick Simon no I was
thinking more Melissa yes I absolutely
thought of Melissa
you